TAPE, JAMES COMEY SAYING THAT HE
HAS NEVER WATCHED "HANNITY,"
TALKING ABOUT ME.
WE WILL COVER ALL OF THAT OF SO
MUCH MORE IN TONIGHT'S BREAKING
NEWS MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
IF YOU BOTHERED WATCHING A FAKE
NEWS MEDIA IN THE PAST 24 HOURS,
WHICH I DO NOT RECOMMEND,
YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED THEY HAVE A
NEW OBSESSION, AND A NEW TARGET
TO FEIGN THEIR MORAL OUTRAGE AT,
AND THEY HAVE DECIDED TO
HYPERVENTILATE AND GO
WALL-TO-WALL WITH HISTORICAL
COVERAGE APPROACHED ME.
NOW THE MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY
HAS ZERO CREDIBILITY.
WE HAVE KNOWN THIS FOR OVER A
DECADE.
WE HAVE BEEN EXPOSING THE MEDIA
FOR WHAT THEY REALLY ARE.
THEY ARE FRAUDS.
THEY ARE PARTISAN HACKS.
AND FRANKLY, NOTHING MORE THAN
EXTENSION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, ALL THINGS LIBERAL.
AND PRETTY MUCH ALL THEY DO A
SPIRITUAL LIBERAL TALKING POINTS
AND OF COURSE, ATTACK
PRESIDENT TRUMP 24/7, ALL IN AN
ATTEMPT TO DAMAGE, DELEGITIMIZE
HIS PRESIDENCY.
NATURALLY, WHEN PEOPLE DARE TO
TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT, AND HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, AND REPORT ON
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER SCANDAL IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, YEAH, I'M NOT SURPRISED
I BECOME A 24/7 TARGETS.
THE MEDIA WANTS TO TEAR THIS
PRESIDENT DOWN.
THAT IS WHAT THEY WANT.
HATE ANYBODY THAT DARES TO
CHALLENGE THEIR RIGID, RADICAL,
LEFT-WING IDEOLOGY.
NOW ALL OF THIS PERFECTLY
EXPLAINS WHY THEY HAVE BEEN
GOING SO HARD AFTER ME AND JUST
SIMPLY REFUSED TO BELIEVE THE
TRUTH THAT I TOLD THEM.
BY THE WAY, IT IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME THEY HAVE DONE IT TO ME AND
OTHERS AND IT WON'T BE THE LAST.
NOW THANKFULLY, PEOPLE ARE
SAYING WHAT IS HAPPENING.
OTHER CONSERVATIVES ARE CALLING
AT THIS MASSIVE DOUBLE STANDARD.
THIS HYPOCRISY, FROM THE LIBERAL
MEDIA, AND GOD KNOWS THESE
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS WANT TO IT
THEMSELVES.
EARLIER TODAY, THE KING OF TALK
RADIO, RUSH LIMBAUGH, THE GREAT
ONE MARK LEVIN, BOTH EXPOSING
WHAT THE LIBERAL MEDIA IS DOING.
LET'S START WITH RUSH, WHAT HE
SAID ON HIS RADIO SHOW EARLIER
TODAY.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT THIS
SO-CALLED ATTACK ON SEAN HANNITY
IS, WHAT IT REALLY, REALLY IS.
IT IS ANOTHER, AND A LONG LINE,
AND A MANY YEARS OF EFFORT TO
DESTROY THE CREDIBILITY OF
ADVOCATES FOR CONSERVATIVE
CONSERVATIVE/REPUBLICAN OR
ANTI-DEMOCRAT ISSUES AND
PERSONALITIES.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS NOT TO
PUT HANNITY IN LEGAL JEOPARDY,
ALTHOUGH THEY WOULD LOVE TO IF
THEY COULD.
BUT THE REAL PURPOSE HERE IS TO
SIMPLY DISCREDIT HANNITY AS A
KNOWN EFFECTIVE PUBLIC ADVOCATE
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE ENEMY.
DONALD TRUMP MUST BE SENT
PACKING.
DONALD TRUMP MOST NOT
POLITICALLY SURVIVE.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE
EFFECTIVE CASES FOR TRUMP ARE
GOING TO BE HIT AND ARE GOING TO
BE TARGETED.
BUT THERE IS SO MUCH GLARING
HYPOCRISY.
HYPOCRISY NEVER STICKS TO THESE
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT.
THE DEFINED COLLUSION.
THEY DEFINE CONFLICT OF INTEREST
THEY DEFINE CONFLICT OF INTERES
INTEREST.
THEY ARE ARCHITECTS OF DECEIT.
THEY ARE NEVER FORTHCOMING ABOUT
WHO THEY REALLY ARE.
AND IF YOU TRY TO FIND OUT, IF
YOU TRY TO DO AN INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER AND SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE, THEY START SQUEALING
LIKE STUCK PIGS, THAT YOU CAN'T
BECAUSE THEY ARE PROTECTED BY
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
THEY ARE JOURNALISTS, AND AS
SUCH, THEY ARE NEVER THE STORY,
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT THEM.
>> Sean: AN AMAZING TAKEDOWN
BY RUSH.
AND HE'S RIGHT.
THE MEDIA CANNOT STAND THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE LIKE US
THAT CHALLENGE THE LIBERAL,
PARTISAN WORLDVIEW.
THEY HATE THAT WE WANT TO LICK
COUNTRY UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
ACTUALLY SUCCEED AND HELP THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
UNDER POVERTY COME OUT OF THE
LABOR FORCE, ON FOOD STAMPS, THA
LABOR FORCE, ON FOOD STAMPS, THT
WE BELIEVE IN THE CONSTITUTION,
THAT WE BELIEVE IN EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW, EQUAL APPLICATION
UNDER THE LAW.
WE SUPPORT REAGAN STYLE
FREE-MARKET PRINCIPLES AND A
STRONG NATIONAL DEFENSE.
NOW THE MEDIA ALSO CAN'T STOMACH
THAT WE EXPOSE THE DEEP STATE.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST ABUSES OF
POWER IN AMERICAN HISTORY, WHICH
THEY HAVE BEEN A IGNORING,
DESPITE MOUNTAINS OF EVIDENCE
FOR MONTHS, AS THEY GO WITH THER
UNPROVEN CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
SO I'M NOT SURPRISED THAT THE
MEDIA'S GOING AFTER ME.
IT'S PREDICTABLE, IT'S PATHETIC.
HERE'S THE TRUTH.
THE MEDIA IS GUILTY OF EVERY
SINGLE SOLITARY THING THEY HAVE
BEEN ACCUSING ME OF OVER THE
LAST 24 HOURS.
THE MEDIA IS THE SEWER.
THEY ARE THE SWAMP.
AS PART OF THIS INCESTUOUS,
CORRUPTION AND CONFLICT, AND
THEY SURE AS HECK DON'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT OR CARE ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY.
HERE IS JUST A FEW EXAMPLES WHY.
TAKE A LOOK AT ABC NEWS DORTCH
OF ANAPOLIS, THE SO-CALLED
JOURNALISTS ARE SECURE THE
VERSION.
WITH DISGRACED FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY, THE GUY
WHO WAS LITERALLY CARRYING OUT A
PERSONAL VENDETTA AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DID GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS EVER
DISCLOSED THE FACT THAT DURING
THE INTERVIEW THAT HE WORKED ON
BILL CLINTON'S '92 CAMPAIGN AND
WAS THEIR COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR AND THEN SERVED IN THE
CLINTON WHITE HOUSE AS A SENIOR
ADVISOR?
SINCE THE LIBERAL MEDIA APPEARS
TO BE SUFFERING FROM AMNESIA,
HERE'S A CLIP FROM A
DOCUMENTARY, IT IS CALLED "THE
WAR ROOM."
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS ADVOCATING
FOR THE CONTENTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I CAN GIVE YOU NAMES,
ADDRESSES, PHONE NUMBERS OF WHO
YOU HAD AN AFFAIR WITH.
IT WOULDN'T MAKE IT TRUE.
IT IS COMPLETELY BELIEVE.
IF YOU WANT ON THE RADIO AND
SAID THAT BILL CLINTON IS THE
FATHER OF AN ILLEGITIMATE BLACK
CHILD, YOU'D BE LEFT OUT.
PEOPLE WOULD THINK YOU ARE
CRAZY.
I GUARANTEE YOU THAT IF YOU DO
THIS, YOU WILL NEVER WORK IN
DEMOCRATIC POLITICS AGAIN.
MAYBE YOU DON'T WANT TO COME I'M
NOT SAYING IT MATTERS.
YOU WILL BE EMBARRASSED BY THE
NATIONAL PRESS CORPS.
PEOPLE THINK -- NOBODY WILL
BELIEVE YOU AND PEOPLE WILL
THINK YOU ARE SCUM.
>> Sean: YOU'LL BE
EMBARRASSED.
NEVER WORK IN NATIONAL POLITICS
AGAIN.
HE SOUNDS LIKE A THREAT.
DID GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS REVEAL
ANY OF THAT, BEFORE, DURING,
AFTER THIS IT DOWN WITH CONNIE,
REMIND HIS AUDIENCE?
HOW ABOUT HE DONATED 75 GRAND TO
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION, WHICH HE
DIDN'T REVEAL TO HIS VIEWERS
DURING AN INTERVIEW WITH PETER
SCHWEIZER BACK IN 2015.
STEPHANOPOULOS HAD TO APOLOGIZE
AFTER BEING EXPOSED.
BUT THERE WAS NOT WALL-TO-WALL
COVERAGE OF THAT.
AND ALL THAT EXPLAINS WHY
STEPHANOPOULOS PUT ON THE KID
GLOVES I DIDN'T ASK JAMES COMEY
THE TOUGH QUESTIONS.
NOW ONE THING IS JUST THE FACT:
I AM HONEST ABOUT WHO I AM AND
WHAT MY POLITICAL BELIEFS ARE.
IN UNAPOLOGETIC CONSERVATIVE.
I AM A TRUMP SUPPORTER.
I SUPPORT REAGAN ECONOMIC
POLICIES AND PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHERE IS THE
FOLLOW-UP QUESTION WHEN COMEY
ADMITTED HE DIDN'T TELL
DONALD TRUMP THAT
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR THE
UNVERIFIED DOSSIER, WHICH BY THE
WAY HE WAS USED TO GET A FISA
WARRANT TO SPY ON AN AMERICAN.
WATCH THIS.
>> DID YOU TELL HIM THAT THIS
BAT DOSSIER HAD BEEN FINANCED BY
HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS?
>> NO.
I DIDN'T USE THE TERM STEELE
DOSSIER.
I JUST TALKED ABOUT ADDITIONAL
MATERIAL.
FIGURE DID HE HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW
THAT?
SPEAKETH THAT IT HAD BEEN
FINANCED BY HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENTS?
IT WASN'T NECESSARY FOR MY GOAL,
WHICH WAS TO ALERT HIM THAT WE
HAD THIS INFORMATION.
>> Sean: GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS, HE'S A
JOURNALIST, RIGHT?
WHY DIDN'T HE ASK COMEY TO
RESPOND TO THE INFORMATION IN
THE GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO THAT
THE BULK OF THE FISA APPLICATION
TO SPY ON A TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE CONSISTED OF THE
DOSSIER THAT HE DIDN'T VET.
HE HAD A LEGAL OBLIGATION AND
FBI PROTOCOL OBLIGATION TO DO.
WHY DIDN'T STEPHANOPOULOS ASK IF
COMEY APPLIED TO A FISA COURT
AND FEDERAL JUDGES ON FOUR'S
SEPARATE OCCASIONS BY NOT
REVEALING THAT THE DOSSIER
WAS FUNDED BY HILLARY CLINTON
AND THE DNC WHOSE FINANCES SHE
CONTROLLED.
WHY DIDN'T HE ASK COMEY TO
RESPOND TO WHAT IS FORMER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE SAID
ABOUT THE DOSSIER, WITHOUT IT,
THERE NEVER WOULD HAVE BEEN A
FISA APPLICATION.
AND THE LIST GOES ON.
NOW STEPHANOPOULOS, HE LOBBED
SOFTBALL QUESTION AFTER SOFTBALL
QUESTION, NEVER CHALLENGED OR
PRESSED COMEY.
WHY SHOULD HE?
HE GOT THE FIRST INTERVIEW.
HE'S FRIENDS WITH THE CLINTONS.
OVER THEIR FAKE NEW CNN, YOU
HAVE JAKE TAPPER, I WILL LET THE
GREAT ONE, MARK LEVIN, HANDEL
GREAT ONE, MARK LEVIN, HANDEL  H
GREAT ONE, MARK LEVIN, HANDEL  N
GREAT ONE, MARK LEVIN, HANDEL  L
GREAT ONE, MARK LEVIN, HANDEL  E
HIS PART.
>> JAKE TAPPER, HE WAS A
SPOKESMAN FOR A CONGRESSWOMAN OR
WAS FROM THE 13TH CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT OF PENNSYLVANIA.
HER SON MARRIED CHELSEA CLINTON.
I MENTIONED THAT, TOO.
DID JAKE TAPPER EVER MENTIONED
THAT?
NO.
DID JAKE TAPPER MENTIONED THAT
HE WAS A SPOKESMAN FOR HANDGUN
CONTROL INCORPORATED?
NO.
>> Sean: FAKE NEW CNN, DID
THEY EVER DISCLOSE ANY OF THAT'S
WHEN HE HOSTED CNN'S GUN-CONTROL
TOWN HALL A FEW MONTHS AGO?
I WONDER IF JAKE IS GOING TO
DISCLOSE ALL OF THIS ON HIS SHOW
TOMORROW.
I DOUBT IT.
NONE OF THIS SHOULD BE
SURPRISING.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC INTEGRITY, BACK DURING
THE CAMPAIGN, 96% OF
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN DONATIONS
FROM JOURNALISTS, THEY WANT TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
YOU HEARD ME RIGHT.
96%.
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE, WHAT THEY
NOW COMPLAIN ABOUT THEIR
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS AND
THEIR SUPPORT FOR
HILLARY CLINTON?
WHAT ABOUT AS WIKILEAKS EXPOSED,
TOP JOURNALISTS FROM ABC,
BLOOMBERG, CNN, MSNBC,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," MANY OF
THESE OUTLETS, REMEMBER THEY
DINED AT A KEY CLINTON STAFFER'S
HOUSE RIGHT BEFORE HILLARY
LAUNCHED A CAMPAIGN, EACH OF
THEIR FOOD, DRINK THEIR WINE?
OF ALL OF THOSE JOURNALISTS DID
IN FACT ATTEND, WHY DIDN'T THEY
TELL YOU ABOUT IT?
OR HOW ABOUT THESE
RELATIONSHIPS?
TO THE MEDIA FIND THESE
PROBLEMATIC?
YOU HAVE REPORTS, A SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT AT CNN MARRIED TO
A MAN WHO SERVED AS THE UNDER
SECRETARY OF STATE FOR
HILLARY CLINTON.
CLAIRE SHIPMAN, REPORTER, ABC,
MARRIED TO A FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY JAY CARNEY.
FORMER OBAMA NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR SUSAN RICE, HER HUSBAND
USED TO WORK AT ABC NEWS.
DOES THE MEDIA FIND ANY OF THIS
TROUBLING?
THIS IS ONLY A SMALL SAMPLING OF
STUFF I CAN BRING UP.
DID THEY RAISE RED FLAGS ABOUT
ANY OF THIS?
THEN THERE IS THE EPITOME OF THE
WASHINGTON, D.C., SEWER AND
SWAMP.
THE DOZENS OF JOURNALIST THAT
WENT TO WORK FOR THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
MEDIA RESEARCH POINTED OUT THE
TOTAL NUMBER REACHED AS HIGH AS
30.
IT GOT SO BAD THAT BACK IN 2013,
EVEN THE LIBERAL
"WASHINGTON POST" WAS FORCED TO
COVER IT AT ASK THIS QUESTION.
SO WHAT TO MAKE OF ALL OF THE
FAMILY TIES BETWEEN THE NEWS
MEDIA AND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
GREAT QUESTION.
THE ANSWER IS NOTHING.
NO ONE IN THE MEDIA CARED
BECAUSE THEIR SAVIOR, THE CHOSEN
ONE, BARACK OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT.
IF A FOX NEWS CHANNEL
CONTRIBUTOR GOES TO WORK FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE, GOD HELP US ALL.
IT WAS THE HIGHLIGHT OF THE
JOURNALISTS CAREER TO SUCK UP
AND DEFEND OBAMA'S DISASTROUS
RECORD.
THEY NEVER INVITED HIM AND THEY
NEVER TOLD HIM HOW BAD HIS
ACHIEVEMENTS OR LACK THEREOF
WERE AFRAID THE MEDIA DOES NOT
CARE ABOUT FACTS, THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT HOLDING THEMSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY HAVE VOTED AS A CLEAR,
OBVIOUS LIBERAL AGENDA AND
THEY SHARE A COMMON GOAL WITH
LIBERALS IN THIS COUNTRY, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY WANT TO
DESTROY THE PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE SHOWED YOU THE REACTION
ON ELECTION NIGHT WAS LIKE A
FUNERAL.
THEIR ATTACKS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, IT IS GETTING MORE
UNHINGED EVERY DAY.
FOR THE MEDIA TO PRETEND THEY
HAVE ANY SORT OF MORAL AUTHORITY
IS JUST LAUGHABLE.
IT'S A JOKE AND YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, NO ETA.
THAT IS MY POLL AFTER POLL SHOWS
YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT AND YOU
DON'T TRUST THEM AND YOU SEE THE
VICE FOR WHAT IT IS.
WE ARE GOING TO END WITH THIS
KEY POINT.
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA, THEY HAVE
PUT THEIR BLINDERS ON AND ARE
PURPOSEFULLY IGNORING A MASSIVE
SCANDAL, WHICH WOULD BE THE
BIGGEST STORY IN THEIR
LIFETIMES.
AND IF THEY CARE SO MUCH ABOUT
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST, LIKE THEY
CLAIM, DARE THEM TO REPORT ON
THIS CORRUPT MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AND HIS TEAM THAT
IS STACKED FULL OF DEMOCRATIC
DONORS, AND TO MUELLER'S FRIENDS
WITH JAMES COMEY AND COMEY HAD A
FRIENDLY COULD POTENTIALLY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION TO THE
MEDIA SO THAT MUELLER COULD
BE APPOINTED AND MUELLER HAS
ASSEMBLED A TEAM THAT HAS
DONATED OVER 50 GRAND TO OBAMA,
DEMOCRATS, HILLARY, AND THE DNC.
GAVE NO MONEY TO DONALD TRUMP.
AND MUELLER HANDPICKS ANDREW
WEISSMANN, WHO HAS THE MOST
ATROCIOUS TRACK RECORD,
INCLUDING WITHHOLDING
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE, AND